less oh wait a minute
get this out of the way all right and we
are live again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
gonna come Wednesday mornings I'm gonna
try to do it every Wednesday around 10
at 10 A.M so stay tuned for that sorry
for the confusion but welcome
today we're talking about the Chris Rock
special the consultant on Prime real
world advice from a grown ass man is
back and a couple of other things but we
are live in full effect thanks for being
here as always and you know what we do
[Music]
oh my God
all right welcome everybody welcome back
to riffing with Griffin it's good to see
everybody thanks for being here live uh
you know how we do we got a new uh we're
doing it on a new day I just Tuesdays
was just becoming too difficult to do it
live I was doing other podcasts on
Tuesdays and it's just like it's a lot
so I was like let me alleviate some of
my stress and just do this on a
different day but anyways thanks for
being here this is we're from with
Griffin go to Eric griffin.com
want more news and notes from me uh you
know subscribe everybody subscribe you
gotta subscribe you gotta hit the
notifications uh so you could uh you
know know when I'm going live and when
I'm posting things and I'm on Twitch
most days you know I'm gonna be on
Twitch later today I have a lunch
meeting but I'm going to be on Twitch
after that and if you want to support
the show you can support the show on
Twitch
um there's my alarm sorry you can
support the show by being a subscriber
on Twitch or you can just be a
subscriber on patreon uh so now that
I've switched days I'm gonna figure out
uh how I'm gonna come in and do a sort
of like not daily thing on my patreon
but like a you know uh you know the
morning news with Griffin something like
that I'm I'm getting it all set up I
know I said it every week but I am
relaxed we're gonna do it all right
and so uh let's just take care of a
little business before we start
um we want to thank the sponsor of our
show doordash I want to thank doordash
for sponsoring the show Good get 50 off
up to twenty dollar value and zero
delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code Griffin also
a great sponsor of the show is kick off
kick off don't let your credit control
you go to kickoff.com and start building
Better Credit in less than five minutes
that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com and take control of your
credit right now
all right everybody what's uh going on
thanks for being here uh I want to thank
everybody that's listening you know if
you're listening later on Apple or at uh
Amazon or how excuse me however you
listen to podcasts thank you please uh
write comments and share and give me
five stars because that stuff helps push
the the podcast up to the top with the
algorithm
but you know and I think everybody in uh
I want to thank all the people in the in
the chat too you know you guys are great
thanks for you know thanks for doing
what you do too you know what I mean
um so that's great for you guys being in
the chat I see all you guys there you
know talking smack
you know what I mean so it's like it is
what it is so thanks for being here
um wait let's go to wait let me see wait
let me go to this
you know we'll be doing it when we doing
it live when we doing it live it takes a
little second to get everything in order
let me make sure I got
uh all my uh
you know it's weird how the the phone
doesn't necessarily sync with your
computer I mean the Apple universe is
actually pretty good the way it
integrates you know what I mean but
sometimes you don't know when it's doing
it you know what I mean it's like what
when is it sending the pictures over to
your computer and when is it not you
know it's just it's really bizarre so I
don't know I should I probably should
have checked that earlier but it is what
it is
you know how we do here
um what's I went uh we had I was in
Vegas so I want to thank everybody that
uh I want to thank everybody that came
out to Vegas uh to see me at the Jimmy
Kimmel Comedy Club so shout out to Jimmy
Kimmel comedy club that was uh that was
that was really fun
um
you know the uh you know there's so much
competition in Vegas you know when
you're when you're in Vegas and you're
trying to do
you know anything it's like there was
the fights it was NASCAR
um right across from the Jimmy Kimmel
comedy club is this like theater that
has these like like all these kind of
like punk bands and emo stuff and it was
a lot you know what I mean it was a lot
of um
stuff and we still have some great
crowds so shout out to everybody that
came out in Vegas that was pretty cool
and uh let's see um
let me see what we got
some some comments we got right now
uh let's see
let's see let's see let's see is I don't
even know I mean I I have some comments
ready to go
let's see Mary H I love you so much Eric
the rap at the end it was so funny and
goofy I had to rewind and watch it a
couple times that's what you guys got to
wait for for the rap recap
so Mary H thanks for you know writing it
out
uh okay uh then Riley or Raley it must
be Riley show show wand show walls or
weird name I don't know I'm so sorry I
butchered your name but my son Joel was
named after the last of us it was a
deadly game man wow so that's somebody
that really likes the game
let's see
um
uh somebody house money Aunt those Volvo
EVS are kind of Saucy but yeah 225 mile
range is crazy
bananas they're Volvo thinks they could
sell a car
that only goes 225 that they're claiming
225 miles believe me that's in true
mileage after using the AC and driving
uphill and driving fast and and the
radio and and that is going to go 110
miles tops uh you know you're going to
be so disappointed that car is that that
is crazy to me Eric Sanchez up in the uh
in the chat right now thank you for the
uh Super Chat appreciate you that's how
you also can support the show and I
appreciate that let's see another few
more comments
uh Trevi loving The Last of Us haven't
even cared or noticed uh political
statements you claim to see but I guess
being gay or lesbian Tommy marrying a
black woman is political you you getting
old man
[Laughter]
your crate the fact that you wrote that
means you you you you see exactly what
I'm saying I love when people say
like that it's like when people
say I don't see color like what are you
colorblind like you you just saying that
means you see color you know what I mean
it's just like last of us is an
absolutely fantastic show but don't
think for a second they not making not
political statements but you know social
statements
it's like they're going hey we're gonna
do different stories and I'm all for it
I'm not against it I'm all for it the
more they do things like that the more
it will be normalized in our culture and
when we then we truly won't see it you
know what I mean but for you to act like
you're I'm a good person so I never see
race or color or sexual orientation yeah
listen I call
anyways
um
somebody else Anonymous hippopotamus
funny name they should have built the
Chevy Volt idea Eevee that switches to
gas when you need it I actually 100
agree
I think they should have some sort of
hybrid maybe you have a little gas tank
that's just for emergencies you know
what I mean so I totally agree with you
on that anyways
um we're here we're from with Griffin uh
thanks for all the comments if you want
to comment you'll get your comment read
to uh out here but anyways like I said I
was out in Vegas and it was uh it was it
was really fun I had a good time in
Vegas so thanks for coming out like I
said and if you want to see me I don't
know if you're in the Santa Rosa area
I'm not even sure if this is a private
show I gotta look I think it's a public
show but I'm gonna be at the Boys and
Girls Club on the 11th my birthday is
actually on the 12th so make sure you
come check that out all right gotta make
sure I got my real world advice stuff
ready to go
um
what's going on
um weird story in the news real quick uh
I thought I you know I like I get these
weird news stories from my uh shout out
to my producer Kristen Espinoza she
sends me some great stuff but this is
one of them that I thought was like this
is some bizarre ass stuff right here
y'all
I don't know if you if you've even seen
this but a family raises a 250 pound dog
for two years and then realizes it's a
bear
what
like
at what point are you like
this dog is getting big
how do you not know
a dog is a bear
like
when you what like so you raising it and
it's just eating stuff
it's eating you out of house and home
it's getting huge
what dog
it'd be one thing if it was like a wolf
it'd be one thing
if it was like a uh that's the only
thing I can think of a coyote
or you know but it would be like
it's like you you think this is a house
cat
right let's say you think this is a
house cat and then
six months in it's a it's a tiger
and you're like oh this house cat is
just getting big what are you talking
about man at least a tiger when it's a
little it looks like
freaking cat right they look the same
a bear and then in the story The the
couple is saying like yeah we were kind
of getting concerned that the dog was
walking on its hind legs
this bear should ate both of them
I actually even believe this story but
it was in the New York Post
you know as I think because of Like
Cocaine Bears out which I haven't seen
and I want to go see that and I'll give
you guys a good review but it's just
like what are you talking about even
when they showing the the thing as a
little baby dog quote unquote it looked
it looked like a bear like you've never
seen a bear before like how ridiculous
would that be like
you have a little puppy and then you
know because these stuck suckers grow
fast two years later it's a 250 pound
bear like you like
at what point are you like yo we gotta
get this out of here like is it roaming
around the house like imagine you go to
somebody's house and you know how dogs
and stuff jump on you you know they got
a bear that's on his hind legs and
they're like oh this is Fluffy are you
like what get yourself monster out
of my face I don't know it's just like
sometimes I feel like people are getting
stupider and stupider as as the as the
years go on huh
somebody said in the chat maybe the bear
was on the Spectrum
inappropriate that's
that is problematic and triggering so
please uh don't say things like that
a bear how you how a bear a bear are you
kidding me
a bear
you know at what point
I wonder like you got a bear it's two
years later and it's a bear and you're
like we should go to the vet yeah um our
dog
is walking on his hind list imagine the
look on the vet's face
when you walk in first of all when you
walk in with a bear on a leash
and that suckers
walking next to them on the time lapse
and you know and they acted like this is
normal yeah uh fluffy is
um walking like this it's kind of is
there something going on and the
doctor's gonna be like that's a bear
dummy you know
I don't know
it was just stupid that's just a dumb
story that sometimes the stuff in the
news you go I don't know if this is true
if I believe this or not you know
personal note like you know you know I
just I just want to say this I think
that
I think that social media
and I'm just coming up with this now
because I was just thinking about it but
I think that social media
needs to be have the same rules as like
any other press or news organization
you know before social media
like
the New York Post or the Washington Post
or L.A times or any news organization
they can't just write a story about
anybody and say whatever they want
they have to be able to have
cooperating evidence they have to have
sources and facts
to to back up their story so if they
want to make a claim about you
they say you did something horrible or
they just want to say anything about you
once they publish that story as the
person is the subject of that story I
then admit enabled to be like yo
I'm suing you or this is against the law
it's not even about being sued it's
against the law
you that's why you rarely see stories
about people
they they in the story they'll be like
these are the you know after talking to
three sources after talking to whatever
here's the facts and this is what we
have and then if you want to refute that
then the person can come back and be
like oh this isn't true but they're
gonna have to prove that
social media to me should fall under the
same category because as of right now
anybody can say anything about anybody
they could just say whatever they want
they could call you names they could say
disparaging things about you they could
they could say whatever they want
and and it's public and you know if you
have a lot of followers
that could be dangerous for someone it
could be it's just you know what I mean
unfair characterization or whatever it
is and it's like I think that because
technology moves so fast that the laws
are not caught up to that another
example of that is like and I've talked
about this before it's how like you know
when you put one of those air tags on
something
like that should be a legal thing now so
let's say I put an air tag in my car and
my car is stolen and the thief takes it
to their house and they put it in their
garage
I call the cops and I go yo I have an
air tag in this and I see exactly where
it is well the cops will get there and
they'll be like well we can't do
anything
we can't do anything because you know we
need a warrant or whatever the thing is
that should be
put into law
it's like oh no no I got an air tag and
I know it's there here's the app the
cops should be able to see that and be
like this is enough for us to go in
get this car my buddy had his my buddy
had his motorcycle stolen and his
friend's motorcycle was stolen and this
is exactly what happened that the
thieves know this and they put the
motorcycle in their apartment and the
dude couldn't do anything the cops were
like look we can't do anything so I'm
saying that's like you got to do
something about that you know what I
mean
so anyways that's just I was just
thinking about that the other day
because you know
I just think that it you should be
careful about the things you say about
people on the internet you know
you should it is you know anyways you
guys don't care whatevers nobody cares
all right let's do some business right
now guys
um
let's do some business let's talk about
doordash y'all doordash doordash we want
to thank
our sponsor doordash
all right
um
get the dash pass off for there's a dash
pass offer for students which I think is
great good first of all let me just say
I use doordash I love doordash you know
I'm on the go on busy Rachel works I
work we're ships in the night sometimes
and then it's time to get together and
we're like hey do we want to go out no
we just want to order from one of our
favorite restaurants that's around here
because we also want to support and you
know doordash is a great way to use that
and they have a bunch of things man with
zero delivery fees exclusive items of
and more than 25
000 members only offers Nationwide
that's when you get that dash pass offer
for students what I'm saying so get uh
get the back to school Savings you
really want and get unlimited free
doordash delivery with dash pass just
4.99 a month for students that's
actually a great deal when you get the
free delivery it really adds up so make
sure you guys check that out you know
sometimes you want to pick up groceries
or you went to the grocery store and you
forgot something that you can get
groceries and Essentials and stuff like
that doordash has a lot of stuff right
uh it satisfies many Cravings that you
might have sometimes we order just
donuts when I'm being a fat but
you know do what you got to do guys but
dash pass by doordash has everything you
need to make this semester memorable
dash pass for students gets you delivery
in an hour or less so you can satisfy
those spur of the moment Cravings are or
save even more five percent doordash
credits back on pickup orders that's
actually great too I take advantage of
that for a limited time our listeners
get 50 off up to twenty dollar value and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code within
that's fifty percent off twenty dollar
value and zero delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code refin don't forget
that's code riffin riffin for 50 off up
to twenty dollar value and zero delivery
fees with doordash subject to change
terms apply
also a great sponsor of the show right
now is kick off that's kick off
kickoff.com don't let your credit
control you listen your credit is such
an important thing I gotta tell you
right now and you could do something
about it to make sure that you have a
good credit score so you can get a good
house so you can get a car with a low
interest rate all that stuff is
important getting ready for the next
step in your life maybe you're thinking
about buying a new car like I'm saying
renting a new apartment having a good
credit score is very important all right
is your credit score getting in the way
of what you you want because that's what
will happen
kick off is here to help you there's no
way around it credit scores are boring
but they still determine whether you get
a sick credit card a good loan for a
house and if you qualify for the new
apartment kickoff makes it easy to put
credit building on autopilot so you can
spend your time doing whatever you want
plans started just five dollars a month
and every one-time payment you make with
kickoff is reported to the major credit
bureaus when they see healthy habits you
see your credit score boost and that is
important
with a 4.9 out of 5 rating in the App
Store and over forty four thousand rave
reviews you can trust kickoff don't let
your credit control you go to
kickoff.com and start building Better
Credit in less than five minutes don't
put it off that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com take control of your
credit right now build your credit the
easy way right now at kickoff.com
all right guys now we've got the
business out of the way let's get to the
main event of what I wanted to talk
about today all right
so
what's going on here why isn't it
switching
what
see this is this this that right
here just just that stuff I'm talking
about man I don't know what's going on
with this let me do this there we go all
right y'all there it is sorry about that
and thanks for being here uh all the
chat all the chatters
um Chris Rock everybody Chris Rock who I
consider a friend you know
yeah you know I I said I sent him a
message I was like great job all right
so first of all Netflix did this new
thing where they tried something new
they experimented and did a live event
so Chris Rock taped his new special live
um
selective what was it called
oh what was the name of this damn the
selected selective outrage which I think
is a great title which is like that sort
of anti-woke movement selective
selective outrage so they tried it live
now as a comic myself I gotta tell you
this
just the fact that they decided to do
this live is amazing okay it's an
amazing thing because you guys don't
understand normally specials and when
you're at this level sometimes they'll
do four shows you're wearing the same
thing and then you pick the best moments
and you piece it together and you put
together a great television show that's
what it is you know I I directed a
special recently my boy Matt Rife which
is out now check out Matt Rife special
right now and so
I know how it is I know the ins and outs
I know how you sometimes you have to
stop in the middle of it because
something happens you there's things
that that go on that happen live that
you never see as an audience member you
just see this finished product that that
has been chopped up the best versions of
the jokes the best thing is put together
so the fact that he did this live
um
you know it's great you know and then
and then he flubbed a joke and even said
it it made it really authentic as if you
were experiencing this concert live in
your house like as if you were there
it's a tough thing to do and not
everybody can pull it off I mean I've
had great live shows that I when I
finish I go oh man I wish I was Taping
that but you never know so anything
could have happened and they
experimented with it and I thought it
was great you know I think Netflix is
going to move into Live Events and I
think that's you know it's cool it was a
cool thing
but now let's get to it what do I think
about the special overall like I said if
you're watching a live performance you
know there were ups and downs but I
think Chris Rock was in his bag man you
know he's one of the greats man he's on
the Mount Rushmore Comics all right he's
one of the greats okay and he was in it
you know he was entertaining he was
doing the Chris Rock thing that he does
he was making his points he was being
funny and I thought that he did a great
job
um you know I thought it was an
enjoyable watch you know what I mean
with as many specials that are on
Netflix right now and so many of them
are bad and then they weren't live I
tell you so so think of that too there's
a lot of specials that are on Netflix
right now where you're like ah that was
okay and they probably did two or four
shows and this is the thing they put out
and Chris Rock just doing it live in the
pocket uh was just I thought it was uh
fantastic you know
um but you know it is what it is it's
like I said he did a live thing you know
what I mean
um but really the whole point of this
whole thing right now is we want to you
know do we get to the end the last 10
minutes where are you he talks about
what he hasn't addressed in a year is
this slap by Will Smith
from at the Oscars so let's go back to
it okay because I talked about it last
year and I'm gonna talk about it again
all right
Chris Rock
made a dad joke okay
uh
you I can't wait to see you in GI Jane
too his wife's bald it's it's it's it's
he wasn't a surprise guest at the Oscars
well there's he's already hosted the
Oscars before you know what you're gonna
get with Chris Rock he made a joke first
of all he compared her to a female hero
so
who I feel bad for is Demi Moore because
apparently being compared to Demi Moore
is the worst thing you could possibly do
the guy did a dad joke he might as well
said pull my finger that's what he he
might as well have said that pull my
finger it was just a dad joke Okay so
let's say
you are like oh you're one of these
who's like oh my God I can't
believe that he said that and all right
you're upset about that eh you're a
in my opinion all right you a
little fragile okay so it's like
it's a joke you know what I mean like
let's get over ourselves we're taking
ourselves way too serious and by the way
in that moment everybody laughed Will
Smith included okay
now
I'm gonna go on your side and be like
all right if you think that was the most
out of pocket thing you could possibly
say
commercial break Will Smith could get up
go to the back and be like yo dog please
don't talk about my what I don't know
what your problem is he could have
handled that in a whole host of ways we
could have heard about it later Will
Smith steps to Chris Rock like at you
know hey man and then they had an
altercation and we'll never really know
what happened but we would then you
could be like well you know Chris Rock
said that joke maybe he shouldn't have
if that's how you feel about it I'm with
you I'm like okay he went he handled it
I wouldn't be like that you know what
I'm saying it would just be like you
know I think you would have thicker skin
if you're people like this okay
and by the way like I said that joke was
nothing that's a nothing joke it's a
throwaway joke you know you know what
I'm saying like
what he did in this special
that's what he could have done
at the Oscars
all that information was out about them
he could have done all that at the
Oscars then I'm like oh you you might
want to go up and punch this dude right
it'll but that's not what he did that's
not what he did he did a dad joke okay
you know the point is about time and
place
Chris Rock's a better man than me
because I would have called the police
on that dude you you have to remember
this too he was slapped assaulted on
National Television no charges were
pressed and there was no arrest that's
you you guys forget that all you fragile
sensitive ass people who are just like
oh my God we need to remove comedy from
society comedy is the worst thing ever
in society making fun of ourselves and
other people is we that needs to be
removed
associate violence okay how about that
let's not forget that
on the most important day of this dude's
professional career he made a blunder
and there was no repercussions for it in
the moment that that could have been
okay
he could have been arrested but Chris
Rock was like nah that's okay and he was
a pro took the hit and then went on with
the show because there's 40 million
people watching
he could have got him arrested and could
have sued him and the Oscars
anyway
what he did in his special
Justified
I see a lot of people you know I've seen
comments and people like oh he should
get slapped again see y'all forgot what
happened
a dude made a innocuous dad joke
and got assaulted on television
and now he's coming back being like all
right now it's my turn and he doesn't
use his fists he uses intellect and he
got him
so now we hear his side of the thing and
y'all still
y'all still like oh Clinton wrong that
was terrible I can't believe this
you know it's like it's like the whole
situation you have to look at the whole
thing you have to look at the whole
thing okay the whole thing how this went
about
hurt people hurt people you know
whatever is going on with that family is
ridiculous
I mean I agree with Chris Rock about
like why would you
talk about that stuff publicly then
you're going to talk about that stuff
when you put stuff out publicly you open
it up for scrutiny criticism and for
comments that's why you do it you have a
show on Facebook live on Facebook that
has a comment section
you you are opening it up for comments
did Chris Rock say that stuff on the
Oscars no and he could have and he did
it he was like ah this is inappropriate
but yeah that's what Comics do when
they're on the Oscars that's why they
have them there for comic relief let's
let's poke fun at these people who take
themselves too serious
okay
then
he gets hit and then a year later you
want to act like
act like this is the first instance of
this interaction so now people are
attacking Chris Rock as if this is what
he did last year and they're not the
same what he said on the Oscars and what
he said in his special are not the same
thing they're not even on the same level
you know what I mean
so I I just I just don't get it
uh you know I just don't get it you know
what I mean it's like even if you're
dealing with and first of all Jada Smith
even with her condition whatever the
thing is called she looked great she's
at the Oscars in the front row in a
fabulous dress dress with her rich
husband and their successful lives and
yeah he just poked fun it's like if even
if you didn't like that you just go it
did it rise to the level of that so what
I'm saying is that had nothing to do
with Chris Rock that had everything to
do with was going on in their
relationship and they took their
business and publicized it out on the
streets and then he reacted to it in a
way he shouldn't have okay the period
there is no justifying Will Smith
ruining the Oscars there's no way in
there's no justifying that how he
handled that was a thousand percent
wrong
he could have he could have hit him up
at a party afterwards he could have went
he could not went to him and even that
wouldn't have been would have been wrong
but there's levels if you feel like Will
Smith is Justified because he's like oh
you talking because y'all are sensitive
asses I get it you know this is this
generation I see there's a in the
chat right now who's just like you know
being a you know what I'm saying I
get it that's this generation you guys
you're not from my generation you know
you can't take jokes I get it comedy's
not your thing I get that so then
therefore when is the time and place to
go because you know who lost Will Smith
lost he lost they canceled all his
movies uh he was shunned shamed in
society he's banned from the Oscars for
10 years and now every time this comes
out he's going to be remembered for that
was it worth it Chris Rock on the other
hand
sold more tickets in his concerts than
he ever has and now he has this Netflix
special that we're still talking about
so it's like who won in the situation
it's like you you're supposed to be a
bigger person you know if you can't take
jokes
then it is what it is you know what I
mean it's like
you know it's it's crazy though there's
just there's Will Smith is the big loser
in this okay he's a big loser you know
the Oscars got a little bump because
that show was boring and it's boring
because of the sensitive liberal types
who want to go on the show and
continuously talk about social stuff
when this is a thing about celebrating
you so they want to ruin the show by
talking and alienating half the country
uh you know they want to alienate half
the country and talk about politics on
this show with the show is just about
celebrating them and everyone watches
movies liberals conservatives
Independents atheists everybody who
likes movies and then the the show is
continuously ruined by political agenda
okay so that's what's happened with that
that's why the ratings are are dropped
every single year the ratings drop
because there's half the country that's
like yeah I don't want to watch this
you know what I mean they're just like
yeah I just you know I'll just see who
won on Google the next day but I don't
want to watch this show because I'm
tired of being preached at you okay so
and I totally that's a fair feeling
you know what I mean that's a fair
feeling so you know what I mean so
however you feel about it however you
feel about it again
if you are someone who feels like if
someone makes a joke about you you are
entitled to attack them physically if
that's your feeling
I don't agree with it
and and and even if I'm like on Will
Smith's side if I'm like yo you be
talking about my wife you know uh
because I'm dealing with whatever I'm
trying to salvage my relationship with
her and I feel like I need to go do
something that wasn't the time or place
he could have stepped to him later
and been like yo what's up
and that's how you handle that okay
anybody that justif like if you I just I
I don't want anything to do with anybody
that thinks it was okay to do that in
that setting or even just like you know
put put to violence because look Will
Smith lost he lost
okay he lost this battle so cut to now
this special
so you get slapped on live television
yeah you get to you get to come back and
uh do what you do and that's what he did
and I praise him for it he it was
deserved if you didn't like it well that
and that's what I'm saying like compare
the jokes compare CU and GI Jane 2 to
what he did in his special if you think
those two are the same
man you got issues
you have issues like don't ever go to
comedy shows please
don't ever go to comedy shows just be a
keyboard Warrior at your house and never
interact with other people
because I don't want to I don't want to
know someone like that I don't want
someone like that in my life I don't
want you coming to my shows don't go to
other people's shows because you're
going to ruin them with your negative
attitude because you you know
you're you're you're weak-minded that
that's just my feeling I don't want
anybody like that around me
you know what I mean if you think
what happened in Chris Rock special how
he retaliated from being slapped on
National Television if you think those
two are the same like I say you got
issues
you know what I mean you got issues man
so
I think overall if I'm critiquing the
the special itself I I'm giving it a big
thumbs up a lot of woo-woos because I
think that it was it was an interesting
experiment because as a comic I know how
difficult it is to do something live
like that's
like live you you and then no matter
anything can happen and I think you did
a great job I think he pulled it off I
think that you know what we waited for
what we wanted to see we got him talking
about uh what he thinks why he think he
got slapped the history between the the
the the the the the the the the parties
and then how he felt about it and the
jokes he made about it
I think it was hilarious and
I I applaud him for it you know I'm like
yeah that would that was because to me
that's what he could have done on the
Oscars and he didn't
all right so that's that
that's all Daddy has to say about that
issue but well done my friend well done
okay
that's how I feel about it all right
y'all
um wait let me see do I have this I
gotta go quick here let me do a quick
review of uh
let's do a quick review of the
consultant uh out of this this
consultant it's on Prime Kristoff Waltz
is the the star this is a weird ass show
man but I highly suggest you watch it I
haven't seen the end I haven't seen the
end yet so I'm still like I'm on episode
like seven or something I'm like almost
done with the with the series I think
the front half of the series is very
good and fascinating because you're just
like what is this about what's going on
who is this guy why did this happen and
the story that they tell up to the you
know about halfway I think it's pretty
good and he's such a great actor and and
the other people in it are are doing a
great job too man wait let me look this
up real quick I thought I had this
website open but I don't
um
okay uh here we go IMDb the consultant
on IMDb
yeah who are the people Christoph Waltz
Nate wolf and Brittany O'Grady Brittany
O'Grady's doing a really good job on
this too she's I I've watched a couple
of her shows but you know the log line
for the show is follows a relationship
between employee and boss asking how far
you go to get ahead and to survive so
yeah so it's like an interesting like
you know in-office drama like you know
they're in the office and there's this
guy who is like this you know consultant
and how he got the job is very strange
and who is he and what's his history and
what's going on is there some
Supernatural elements and then uh like
how people interact with each other at
their job and like why they do their job
how they get ahead I mean there's a lot
of little other Concepts in it but I
think it's a great watch it's a great
watch so I give it a you know I'll give
it some move oh again let's do all the
woo-woos uh first of all Chris Rock
woo-woo's 10.
and this one probably gets like six
[Music]
so there you go
so the consultant I highly recommend you
watch the consultant uh you know
so and then tell me what you think
um all right let me just get to the the
other part of what I wanted to do today
is the whole reason why
uh let's see let's get to where is it oh
here it is
uh
where is it
oh man
I had a whole now it's not working what
well that sucks
[Laughter]
oh man that sucks my real world advice
from a grown ass man uh uh
um my graphic that I made it's gone what
happened to it oh well
anyways guys
real world advice from a grown ass man
if anybody else has any questions in the
uh
in the um the chat you can
alright so I got a lot of great
questions on Instagram I usually put it
when I do real world advice from a
grown-ups man I get it on Instagram
um you know
and then you know I put do one of those
question things and then people send me
their questions and then I read them
here on the podcast and I and I answer
them
um let's see wait oh man this is
not working properly okay
all right so somebody said how do I get
back out into the dating world I have
been single over a year and I feel so
Rusty and out of sync
I don't know I mean I wish I knew how
old that person was but how do you get
back in the dating world when you
haven't been dating for a year you know
I really think it just depends on your I
think it just depends on your age where
you're coming from with this I mean this
Young Generation right now you guys are
you don't you guys are big on actually
not interacting in real life with human
beings and so you've forgotten that
human beings are communal creatures we
are meant to be around other people
we're designed that way that's why we
have six we that's why we have senses
sight sound smell taste touch
all of these things
when you co-mingle with people
are helpful pheromones body language
unspoken communication is something that
is helpful so a lot of you are so Rusty
because you think swiping right is
dating
now I'm not an old fogy where I'm like
don't you meet people on the internet I
think it's a safe way to vet people
right but get off of it right away so
you meet somebody you read their profile
it interests you but what you really
think is oh I think this person's hot or
whatever it is
get off this right away
get a phone number talk face time you
know whatever send a voice note
something where you can get more senses
and then try to meet go for coffee and
then really right away don't chat with
somebody on the internet for six months
thinking that oh I'm really getting to
know them you're really not there's so
much more about a person when you see
them in person it's so different so to
get off the you know you're Rusty so get
back into it by get on the dating apps
but try to get in person and have and
and and involve more of your senses okay
good luck
all right
um let's see here
so I answered this one on Instagram but
I'll answer it on here too because I
think this is a great one you know as
you know I'm the only child I've never
met my dad before and this guy said my
dad has never been in my life either how
do I completely move on from that
and you know what I found out from being
in therapy is that you don't actually
move on from it or or there's things
about it that you didn't realize was
affecting you what I didn't realize is I
have feelings of Abandonment I you know
for a long time I felt like
I didn't
I didn't think it bothered me you know
I've never met my father before so and I
I thought oh okay well I've never had
them in my life so I don't know what
that's like right so I thought okay it's
not like you're seven and your dad's
like I'm going to get cigarettes and
never comes back then you're like oh my
God you've experienced a great loss but
I actually realized now from in therapy
that you know when I see other people's
families or you watch TV and you see a
father interacting with their son and
you realize oh I've never experienced
that and how that's affected me how I
feel abandoned
how I feel
and how that makes me feel in other
relationships I've had in my life with
friends with uh people that I want to be
considered family you know so it's like
you don't know how this stuff affects
you and so I would suggest like you know
you've never met your father you never
met your mother and there is going to be
something you know you think that oh I
got a handle on this and you can still
survive you could be successful I've had
a great career I've I have money in the
bank I can retire I can you know you
know I'm ready to you know I just love
doing what I do right so I've done I've
done okay but I do see how it's affected
me so I'm telling you out there you may
not see the things that it affects you
you know it's okay maybe maybe get into
some therapy uh maybe actually talk
about this with uh someone you trust you
know so but anyways I totally get that
and good luck
um
let's see how do I deal with a friend
who is a compulsive liar lies about
everything he's 40 years old well you
know look this is the thing how do you
deal with somebody that's a liar that's
a choice you're making if you feel like
the you have a friend in your life that
just lies all the time but you love this
person like this is my friend I love
this person right but you just know oh
my friend is a liar it's just one of
those things you know when your friend
comes and you know when your lying
friend comes it's like yo man uh yeah if
you do just met sting at the at the
Starbucks you and your mind you know you
lying you know what I'm saying so you
just go that's not somebody you trust
with secrets that's not somebody you ask
for advice from but you could still
that's just your friend you know or you
have to let them know man I can't deal
with your lying stop lying I know you're
lying stop lying I can't trust you it
you either have to be open and honest
with them or you just have to accept who
this person is and you just have to deal
with them accordingly there's nothing
else there's nothing really else you can
do
um
and then here's another question
somebody said I'm almost 30 and still
single work long hours any advice on how
to meet someone okay so this just goes
back to the other thing I was saying you
can meet some you know you meet somebody
at work you know what I mean or somebody
has the same interest you know sometimes
people think they forget that they're
walking around in public and you know
your antennas can be up sometimes you
might go to the coffee shop and you see
someone you know you guys you young
people you don't even know how to
approach someone without being creepy
without being whatever and just sparking
up a conversation it's like that is a
lost art
but get on the dating apps man get on
the dating apps and get off of it right
away like I said earlier okay you that I
mean that is just what you have to do
all right
uh um
all right let me go let me find some
other ones
this was a stupid one that I answered on
my Instagram but I'm gonna answer for
you right here for you guys too this guy
goes should I cheat on my my girlfriend
that never gives me sex and when she
does it's lame this is the most entitled
like
this is toxic masculinity and you know
I'm against all that talk but this is an
example of it the dude who thinks he's
entitled to sex as if it's some sort of
like it like like like like it's a foot
rub you know he's critiquing it as if
it's something that is supposed to be
given to him dude sex is a shared
experience it's between you and your
partner you guys are sharing something
together there's intimacy and connection
and something that's happening there's a
give and take that goes on with that and
you got to be like like
if for you to think like she's not
giving it to you there's a reason
there's a reason your partner is not
having sex with you and it may not be it
may be because of you or it could be
something else but communicate
communicate
you know what I mean communicate
talk communicate
and see uh what what's going on
um you know what I mean
that's what you need to do you know you
know what I'm saying so it's like
you know I don't know
I I this guy just
I think that he doesn't realize that
there's something going on there's a
reason why his girl is not doing this
with him and you need to like open up
and find out about that rekindle the
romance in your relationship that's
something that you need to like look
into doing man all right that's uh more
you know that would be more
up your up the alley man instead of
acting like you're you're some King that
is entitled to this you know what I mean
all right
um
I answered this one on my thing too but
this is a great one that I really like
what do you think of a long-distance
relationship you think it'll last or
it's worth it I think long distance
relationships can work if you have a
plan
if you met in person and then like you
guys really connected and there's
something you're like man I gotta be
with you but you go back to your
separate places and now you're having
this long-distance relationship it's not
gonna work if you don't get together uh
you know it's just it's because this
ain't a real relationship relationships
are about compromise and acceptance of
things that you like and don't like and
you only know that by being in proximity
of that person
if you're long distance all the time
then this is just a vacation so when you
go see them you guys are just showing
the best of yourselves and that's it and
then you don't have to worry about them
anymore when you they're out of sight
out of mind when you're like oh doing
your own things there's no like hey are
we getting dinner today hey uh can you
come pick me up or hey um uh you know
can you turn the light off I'm trying to
go to sleep or all that stuff that
happens in a relationship you're you are
you are removing yourself from that and
that's the real stuff and so I think a
long distance relationship can work if
there's a plan in place I'm gonna move
there you're gonna move here or we're
gonna move someplace together because we
want to go long term and you're and
there's a reason you're separated I have
a job I can't leave or I'm at school or
I you know I we need to save up money
whatever that thing is if you have a
plan you're working on together I think
it can work and it's going to be great
you know what I mean but if not what are
you doing
you know what I mean what are you doing
okay let's see let's get a couple more
um not happy with my current job I want
to move but don't want my current boss
to know well it ain't your boss's
business okay let me get sip of my
coffee
hmm
it's not your boss's business honestly
you know
did you know search for another job you
know start putting in resumes you know
start planning out what you want to do
start thinking about how much money do I
need to save that I could be out of work
for two months if if I need to while I'm
searching for another job or maybe I
need to go take a class because I need
to add something to my repertoire so I
can get this other job whatever you need
to do you have to take action plan and
move forward don't just quit your job
and be like well that's it now I'm gonna
go no plan it out man plan it out and
then once you find a job you tell your
boss hey uh give me my two weeks and
then you go that's how you do that okay
but it's all about planning man
um let's see uh
uh a lot of stupid stuff on here too I
mean you know people are just dumb dude
my girlfriend's father died from cancer
this week what's the best possible way
to support her
it sounds like you love your girl and
that's all you really can do you know
you can't take away someone's grief you
can only distract them from it and show
them that life is still moving on you
know what I mean you just gotta be there
that that the moral support sometimes is
enough for some people or sometimes
people need again a distraction so it's
like let's take her you know you just
spend time with her you take her to nice
dinners you you keep her just you know
you keep her moving forward in life get
some workouts in do some activities you
know and just remind her that you know
you know her grandfather it was it her
grandfather I said
um no it's her father so I know how hard
that is
you know it's like that's a tough loss
and she just gotta remind her to
remember the good times and you know
remember to honor her father by living
her best life and you be there just for
support so if you want to do that it's
great you know what I mean so you know I
love it
um
yeah I there's just anyway I'm not even
gonna address it I'm just gonna do what
I did that's how you do that you know I
don't care about these idiots and you
know there's there's so many idiots in
the world and they all come to my chat
ah all right so this is the last one I
got hey Griff myself and my partner love
one another and have been together seven
years we are best friends lovers and
helped one another through some really
difficult times we lived together and
are happy but both of us want to
eventually move home to our family and
friends she wants to go to Canada and I
want to go back to Europe I don't want
to break up over this as everything else
in our relationship is great well you've
already answered your question if
everything else in your relationship is
great then
you gotta decide you know what I mean
it's either worth it or it's not you
know it's it's either hey two times a
year I gotta go travel back to Europe to
see my family and friends or you're like
my family and friends seeing them is
more important than this my life I'm
trying to build with this person okay
you leave the nest man that's why you
leave the nest your home you see your
parents your family you love them you
communicate with them face time with
them more send them letters you know
save up money so you can visit more
often but you are building a life of
your own
okay you're building a life of your own
with this person
if you say all the things that you said
about her stick with it man
you know y'all got to just figure it out
you know what I mean whoa my uh Google
hey Google stop
wow Google just started doing stuff my
Google speaker that was so weird anyways
all right y'all
that's that
um thanks for being here I appreciate
everybody that comes to watch riffing
with Griffin every single week you know
make sure you like subscribe and share
because that is gonna Help Me Grow the
show uh you know if you know if you
don't like what I do this is what I do
on the podcast sometimes it's fun
sometimes it's serious sometimes it's uh
you know introspective sometimes it's
like you know we're doing advice you
know sometimes we're doing
um you know
there's a there's a lot of different
things that I like to do on the podcast
man so it's it's up to you if you like
it or not you know so I appreciate the
ones that do come back every week they
live comments and all that kind of stuff
I appreciate you make sure you check me
out on Twitch I'll be back on Twitch
I'll be here in like say like an hour or
so I'll be back and I'll be on Twitch uh
support me on patreon if you want or you
could be a subscriber on Twitch or you
could be a YouTube member too I
appreciate that support I appreciate
that support too but you know
y'all know what time it is
everybody
it's the rock recap
we talked about the wheel slip Will
Smith
Chris Rock he clapped back
some of my chat you're super wack
oh Ripple Griffin
get the rap recap
that's not a dog that's the bed
did you stand
I would have got scared
new day tell your friends Wednesday
morning every week
you know I'm asleep
my rap ain't weak
that dad's y'all
I turned 51 this week send me gifts
I'm hitting my Peak
oh yeah happy birthday to me
March 12th
as you can see I like to dance and move
my feet
with the rap recap
I do that for me it's so stupid guys
thanks for watching ripping with Griffin
and I'll see you next week every
Wednesday we're gonna try to do it every
Wednesday at 10 A.M and I'll see you
next week thanks for being here thanks
for your support love you take care
foreign